noon all eyes are on nevada today as we  become a crucial turning point in the  2020 election  thanks for being with us for the news  here at noon i'm alex beckett i'm john  langler so plenty of developments this  afternoon the trump campaign has  announced it plans a federal lawsuit  against clark county alleging voter  fraud at the same time  new vote tallies have been released by  the secretary of state's office  so here is a look at the latest results  this is specific to clark county in the  presidential race  you see that former vice president joe  biden leads president donald trump 53  percent of the vote going to the  democrat  that's in clark county here's a look  statewide you can see joe biden  ahead ahead of president donald trump  604  000 votes to 592. those are the latest  results today we don't expect another  update until tomorrow